in the age of social media stars tagging
their plastic surgeons in posts is it
any wonder that cosmetic procedures have
become the new norm a bit of plumping
here a little softening there
Instagram is awash with it which is why
super drugs plans to bring Botox and lip
fillers to its high street stores has
prompted the NHS to speak out we're
saying that the whole of society
actually needs to think again about the
messages we're giving our young and how
we create good mental health we can't
drive illness into society we need to
drive wellness at the moment super drug
is only carrying out a trial but having
met with the NHS it says it's adapting
the hour-long consultations it'll give
to include specific questions about body
dysmorphia it affects around 1 in 50
people but it's most common in teenagers
and young adults ultimately we're giving
customers the choice and the choice that
we're giving them is the ability to come
to super drug and have services that are
provided by qualified nurses in
registered premises and if that leads to
a further debate around the importance
of monetary regulation in the aesthetics
market then all about the problem is
when it comes to cosmetic surgery there
are shocking gaps in patient protection
before we talk about toxin and may ask
your age
David Gately a consultant plastic
surgeon says a lack of regulation makes
it all too easy for unscrupulous
practitioners to take advantage of
vulnerable patients we have a almost 40
percent spike in January and February as
opposed to summer when people go away
and you know that spike might be for
legitimate reasons in terms of holidays
and that they're there they've got some
time off over the Christmas January
period but there will also be an element
of women and men looking at themselves
and thinking you know what what can I do
to improve things and that that can be a
difficult aspect to manage having a
little work done is no longer something
that's embarrassing to admit to for some
it's a badge of honour so while there
seems to be no getting away from the
pressures of unrealistic images the only
realistic step forward according to the
experts has to be greater regulation
Katie Spencer Sky News